is there any easier way that we can make
this mango because it's like that's what
i could keep mushing and mushy cardi b
is learning how to cook latin american
food i don't cook i don't clean but let
me tell you i got this ring although the
28 year old rapper has been honest about
not knowing her way around the kitchen
she's ready to learn now i really want
to learn
how to be an amazing hispanic cook you
know what i'm saying like i feel like i
want to cook like my aunt and my
grandmother i want to come with feelings
in the latest episode of cardi tries the
wap singer taps into her dominican roots
in the kitchen alongside two chefs and
pose actor and fellow dominican india
moore
we did it
she's very excited
cardi first tackled breakfast with a
native dominican dish called mangu but
when it came to using a knife cardi's
signature long nails proved to be a bit
difficult you ain't going baby you're
gonna beat me girl hold on hold on girl
you're gonna be
right
then they tried a traditional spicy
peruvian ceviche
oh yes honey and again cardi's nails got
in her way this is habanero
yeah it's really spicy you can rub this
bowl so you gotta rub it around yeah
i don't think these deals are letting me
you see i was not mentally domestic but
cardi in india pulled it off and learned
a thing or two about how to cook fish
without a flame so the lime yeah so the
lamb cooks this a [ __ ] by itself wow
complete meal by itself i did not know
that girl but you know what now i'm
ready for the world to end
if there's an apocalypse or if the world
ends or something
i want to know that in case i can't make
a fire because i'm really bad at making
fires like if you can't make a fire you
can make a ceviche cardi also learned
how to make papoosas from el salvador
and crushed it using your two fingers
we're going to press a hole in it just
like that
see
see i knew you could do it everybody
said that i can't do things because i
have my nails look
i made them very good okay at the end of
all of cardi's lessons she and india
plated their dishes and presented them
to bold and the beautiful star andy zuno
and mexico's sweetheart angelica maria
we cook this ourselves i hope you like
it you really do yes
i really hope you like it i'm very
scared but did they pass the test and
create authentic food i gotta review my
own thing
oh wow
this chile nogada is for real
it is for real
you are
wow great stars but you are great cooks
huh thank you oh yes the sauce is
perfect
the stuffing is
incredibly dumb
it tastes exactly
exactly the same
so you're good mexican cooks cardi can
now take the stage and the kitchen it
feels really amazing and mind you cardi
is doing all of this not only with her
long nails but while pregnant with her
second child she's since given birth to
a baby boy with husband offset one
thing's for sure
if cardi attempts one of those dishes at
home her family is in for a treat
[Music]
you